up to now sunset has been a piece that
other people have moved about the board
to achieve their own goals using her
discarding her using a fur for a
different purpose you know you're gonna
marry Joffrey no you're gonna marry
Loras you're gonna marry Tyrion she is
beginning to at least try to understand
how she can play the game of Thrones and
be not a piece but a player she's not
even a wild child like Aria she can't
fight with swords but she has her wits
the same as Littlefinger has
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be a video about the winds of
winter excerpted George art Martin just
posted there's also a couple other
things that he announced like winds of
winter coming 2016
you know fingers crossed I know
everyone's pooping their pants about the
Sansa chapter but just to explain what
he said about winds of winter in 2016 he
just said he's canceling everything that
he can to finish winds of winter in 2016
he didn't say at the beginning he didn't
see at the end typically most of his
books have been released in winter time
I don't know a whole lot of about behind
the scenes in the publishing industry in
you know why more books sell in the
winter than they sell in the spring I
know a little bit more about the movie
industry like big movies mostly come out
like tentpole movies in the spring in
the summer but it's not the same for the
book industry really what I would expect
based on the way he's talking about it
is winds of winter earliest you can
expect it is winter of 2016 so like
before season seven to Game of Thrones
that seems pretty realistic like say
like October November of 2016 I don't
expect that estimate to change any time
between now in the end of season 5 like
season 5 only gonna be like 10 weeks
that's nothing in Georgia our Martin
time like if it takes him four or five
years to write a book then the ten weeks
is like a drop in the bucket there is
some news about a TV series that he's
developing at HBO but it's not Game of
Thrones related it's all else mentioned
at the end of this video just careful
for spoilers if you'd want to know
anything about this like really small
Sansa excerpt from winter winter but it
has everyone pooping their pants just a
little bit what's going on in the
excerpt is Sansa going under her
pseudonym Elaine stone remember
Littlefinger gave her a fake name when
they went to the Vale so that no one
would know that she's Sansa Stark so
that's why the name Sansa doesn't appear
a whole lot in the text we find out that
she's planning to work her feminine
wiles on Harold Harding who is the heir
to Robert Aaron our suite Robin this guy
right here up to this point in the books
Littlefinger has passed her off as like
a relatively minor noble so you know
it's much easier to say marry her off to
a lesser person who isn't right in line
for succession
although Harold Harding is actually
pretty close the reason everyone's
pooping their pants is because Sansa is
acting a lot more like Littlefinger
scheming and plotting to win over Harold
Harding so that they'll marry and she'll
be in line to become lady of the Vale if
something were to happen to sweet Robin
so a lot of people are getting the
feeling from this excerpt that
Littlefinger and Sansa are going to plot
to kill sweet Robin
so that Harold Harding will become the
new heir of the Vale and if she's
married to him she'll have control of
the Vale in the timeline of the excerpt
Harold Harding's gaining ready to write
off to a tournament it's the Brotherhood
of the wing night and Sansa wants to
give him her favor so you know kinda
like slowly win him over we see a
picture here of Sansa and Littlefinger
in season 5 at what looks like a
tournament which is a nice twist on
their season one moment when he was kind
of creepin on her a little bit in the
stands it looks like the TV show is
gonna do a version of this but there is
no Harold Harding character so they're
gonna have to substitute someone else
for him if you look here Sansa is in the
crypts in Winterfell so it looks like
some of this might overlap with her
being at Winterfell
so they're gonna blend a lot of those
elements together but there's a lot of
Ramsay Bolton stuff and then there's a
lot of Sansa stuff that don't
necessarily cross over in the books that
might change it went to winter and it
looks like season 5 is going to
incorporate some elements from winds of
winter or these story beats that the
showrunners know george RR martin is
heading for even if he hasn't officially
announced really this Sansa excerpt is
just the latest in several excerpts that
he's released like he'll post a new one
at least once a year there was a really
fun area in Martell one a little while
ago so he'll like you know he'll post
and remove but usually you can find him
somewhere on the Internet but I'll
probably do is I'll do more book videos
as we push through season 5 because I
think by the end of season 5 will be
relatively in line for most things in
winds of winter like there won't be any
more book spoilers to be given there
might be a few small ones so it's always
try to be careful and give spoiler
warnings if I'm talking about stuff from
the books of the show but what this
excerpt is telling you to get hype for
in season 5 is diabolical Sansa she and
Arya on very similar revenge plots Sansa
just has a slightly different mentor
that Arya has Ari's gonna learn from the
faceless men of Braavos she's gonna
become like a real assassin Sansa is
gonna be slaying some beasts too but
she's gonna be going about it in a more
Littlefinger type way I think the real
question is is will she ever ultimately
take back Winterfell I think if this
Vale plot comes off the way they wanted
to the way Sansa and Littlefinger wanted
to she will but if we learned anything
from Game of Thrones is that no plant
goes the way you wanted to if you're not
familiar with the herald Harding
character he's actually the nephew of
Jon Arryn the form
Lord of the Vale remember he was
murdered in the events leading up to
season 1 in book 1 he's Roberts father
or sweet robin's father this guy the
really funny thing about the Vale if
they haven't gotten too deep in on the
show is that Ned in Robert Baratheon
were both kind of raised by Jon Arryn
for a good portion of their life their
young life so a lot of people think that
Robert left a whole bunch more gendry's
just walking around the Vale he was a
noted man-whore his entire life so the
bastards we learned about in season 1
are not the only bastards you just have
to remember that the show kind of
simplifies all these things so like
there were a couple bastards we saw on
the TV show like we saw two notable
bastards like the baby that they killed
in Gendry so if we see any more noble
bastards they'll probably you know much
much fewer number here do you have any
question for you guys who do you think
they're gonna substitute for The Herald
Hardy character in season five of Game
of Thrones because it seems like Sansa
is going to be doing something just a
little bit sneaky I almost forgot to
George or Martin also promised like a
big new WTF character reveal like a big
plot point that he had not previously
considered he didn't say which character
it was for because it's taking him
longer to get wins a winter out he's
thought of some new ideas that he didn't
previously have it could be anything
from mystery bloodlines new abilities
typically when there's like a big
character reveal it's like a character
finding out about parents that they
didn't know they had which I know
everyone's really excited to hear about
especially Jon Snow or it's a character
taking a really WTF action that they
hadn't previously thought about like
Tyrion killing Tywin his diabolical as
Tyrion seems killing his father was a
big turning point so I would think
whatever this new thing is it's gonna be
something on that level for one of the
characters and he didn't say if it was
gonna be a main character or if it was
gonna be a supporting character Martin
also released some details about the HBO
show that he's developing right now just
to clarify it's not Game of Thrones it's
like a sci-fi series like a drama series
about a sci-fi writer in the 1940s
that's writing things that everyone else
is afraid to write about there was a
flashback episode of Star Trek Deep
Space 9 where Sisko ends up being this
sci-fi writer it's like a time-travel
Mindwarp kind of thing where he writes
about ds9
but in the episode he's like a 1940s
1950s sci-fi writer so it's like how
could you think about this space station
with all these aliens in this galactic
war whenever Martin said 1940s sci-fi
writer
is where my mind went he hired a writer
to develop the pilot so don't worry this
isn't going to affect the winds of
winter release it's just gonna be like a
fun new sci-fi show from Georgia our
Martin which i think is actually pretty
cool there hasn't been any news about
the HBO now service that they are
rolling out like HBO GO and a couple
other devices but I'm expecting them to
open it up for subscriptions the HBO
nice stuff at least by next week because
we're like within two weeks of the game
Thrones premiere as soon as that opens
up I'll start using that is the giveaway
like that we'll be able to giveaways for
until then it'll be a $20 Amazon gift
card which reminds me congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Michael fled
EU win a $20 Amazon gift card just be
sure to DM me on the back end of my
channel if you don't know where that is
it's on the about page I just need to
get your contact info so I'm gonna try
and get a new character bonus video out
next week be sure to subscribe to get
that if you have any special requests on
on who you want that character to be
just leave them in the comments if you
haven't seen it yet Jaime Lannister
posted a fun teaser Jaime Lannister
himself you can click here to learn all
about that secret Targaryen thrown
around maybe and you can click here for
my Daenerys Targaryen predictions for
season five thank you so much watching
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you